et moi là ça va
on entend plus
[Rires]
ce que ne savait pas c'est qu'on vient
de passer plus d'une demi-heure en off à
faire plein de réglages techniques et
que monsieur qui a dit non non on passe
en live comme ça on fera les réglages en
effet
la tenez moi donc là
attendez avec ça c'est vraiment ma voix
ici si je coupe la sks que la en mentant
correctement
contentant de monsieur fille ok bon et
ben ça c'est déjà c'est déjà bien et
alors est ce que vous entendez les
invités maintenant parler un petit fait
du bruit d'invités
oui allez
c'est du bruit
j'ai faire les présentations comme ça
vous pourrez désignée
haut à gauche c'est florian kova que
vous avez peut-être vu sur ma chaîne
quand je les ai interviewé à propos de
la fusée expérimentale et qui est
souvent sur le chat d'ailleurs quand je
fais des lives et j'espère bien qu'on
pourra faire un truc que je prenne mes 4
ici j'ai pas pour parler de philo
expérimental par exemple
valentine en dessous donc à valentine
qui faisait oui comme ça vous la
connaissez les diviser en christophe
barbier comme vous l'avez certainement
reconnu au dessus de valentine il y a
joseph de trucs de philo qui est une
chaîne que je partage souvent aussi et à
côté de valentine il y à juliette qui
est présentement qu'est ce que c'est où
est ce que tu es en fait d'ailleurs que
tu change tout le temps de termonde
belgique voilà c'est ça tu en belgique
et en philosophie de la médecine qui
écrit un livre aussi et voilà et que
vous avez peut-être vu sur la chaîne à
quelques reprises aussi tu as fait des
petites apparitions
et oui je fais des cas mais au
célèbre
six mois je pense que je sais une
vignette une petite notoriété sur
twitter quand même je pense à plus
d'abonnés que moi même sur twitter
ça m'étonnerait pas
donc voilà est ce que vous entendez les
différents invités du coup est-ce que
tout va bien est ce qu'on va pouvoir
le son antique doux comme on dit au
québec c'est à dire alors voilà
oui oui ça commence à être mieux j'ai
l'impression
super pas d'autres voilà juste oui
j'étais répondu oui bon bah écoutez on
va partir du principe que c'est bon tout
cas je vous ai préparé à partir d'un
ventre du joseph joseph parle donc un
petit peu est ce que je vous ai déjà
parlé de saint-just
kg il a une obsession à propos de
saint-just
voilà il bizarrement j'ai jamais parlé
de saint-just en live mais c'est étrange
c'est très étrange qui se bat pour quoi
ok super bon et bien donc
pendant toute la journée je me suis dit
allez on va faire à un
qcm de blind test de philo ça me va
amuser sur la dernière vidéo de faire ça
et du coup bref qu'est ce que je veux
dire
on va j'ai lancé le truc aller je suis
un très mauvais présentateur voilà je
suis totalement stressé parce que
techniquement commençait avant ça j'ai
passé la journée à préparer ce truc là
parce que je voulais que ce soit joli et
tout est en fait c'est une galère à
préparer enfin bref on va partir sur
il est où mon truc je n'ai pas perdu
c'est parti
voyons
si je passe sur sa voie là je le vois
regardez j'ai même fait un logo fas il
était dans certains cas et j'ai rien
fait regardez regarde un petit peu comme
chez moi regarder un petit peu à ces
faits musique et la musique oui bah
écoute j'ai pas eu le temps de faire la
musique et où tu peux tu peux le refaire
en
deux
l'important c'est donc l'idée à la
surface
voit la super donc le principe nous
explique le principe sur la première sur
la première question donc le principe
c'est très simple c'est il y à une
citation de philosophes
et vous devez vous allez devoir deviner
qui est le philosophe qui a pondu cette
citation et ses jours alors voilà c'est
chose c'est comme dans ma vidéo cd
thématique ces thématiques philosophie
ce des philosophes qui parle de
philosophie est donc là en l'occurrence
la situation c c'est la marque d'une
infériorité naturel à la pratique de la
philosophie que de s'attarder aux choses
du corps comme de passer trop de temps à
faire de l'exercice à manger à boire à
faire ses besoins à copuler voilà c'est
une authentique citation d'un philosophe
et alors je pour que c'est quand même un
peu plus raisonnable en terme de
difficulté de la chose
je vais ça dépend parfois ina qui sont à
mon avis vous pourrez trouver des
premiers coups celle ci je pensais pas
évident et donc je vais il y aura
plusieurs suggestions de proposition et
vous pourrez répondre et je vais aussi
vous donner un straw poll attendait
alors il faut que je retrouve le truc
c'est une galère comment je fais
ce que je voudrais je devrais pas faire
de bêtises parce que j'ai peur qu'en
faisant un faux mouvement je révèle le
reste du truc du genre passés sur cette
scène là haut up n'envoie pas de toute
façon ouais attendait voilà
je retrouvais le chat parce que je vais
avoir besoin du chat parce que je vais
vous envoyer un straw poll pour que vous
puissiez participer vous aussi quand
même ça serait dommage de voir
participer donc hop j'ai le lien ici et
le chat parce qu'il est le chat
et il me dit que je l'aimais je vois pas
tu bizarre
où es-tu chat
tu te caches mais c'est dingue c'est
caché
oui ce pétrin de chat ce jour c'est sûr
comme ça mais c'est dingue
il me dit que je les quelque part mais
il s'affiche pas attendez une seconde
j'ai relevé retrouver ce chat de merde
respiration assis j'ai retrouvé c'est
bon ça va bien se passer je vais y
arriver
je suis trop vieux pour ces quelques
roquettes un sacré donc voilà comme ça
je peux repasser là je peux remettre mon
powerpoint
vas-y diaporama c'est parti et je
repasse sur la scène voilà comme ça
du coup fameuse bande le straw poll donc
si vous voulez voter donc voir si peu de
propositions donc c'est la marque d'une
infériorité naturel à la pratique de la
philosophie que de s'attarder aux choses
du corps comme de passer trop de temps à
faire de l'exercice à manger à boire à
faire ses besoins à copuler chose que
nous ne faisons pas du coup parce que
nous sommes tous philosophes ici
présents
donc qui a dit ça
le premier première suggestion platon
serait ce plateau
epictète pic de la mirandole
c'est jean son nom
rené descartes
emmanuel kant ou joseph ratzinger haut
saônoise benoît 16
alors donc je vais vous laisser vous
avez le lien du straw poll vous répondez
juste un deux trois quatre singes
celui-ci
je vais essayer 5 puissent les consulter
mais je l'écris sûr ça après et donc
j'ai demandé à mes invités mes invités
de qualité de ne pas tricher en écrivant
une réponse sur un bout de papier et au
moment de répondre quand tout le monde
aura répondu ils montreront ce qu'ils
ont répondu et on pourra ainsi compter
les points d'ailleurs aussi le prends
une petite feuille pour pour relever les
scores alors faisons ça sérieusement
c'est trop dur
germes sont tous les philosophes ont dit
sa maman
tellement ça fait tous
voilà donc on va noter les choses
sérieusement c'est bon tout le monde a
répondu
on le montre à l'écran du coup pas
encore abbassi où tout le monde est prêt
si tourner la tête on attend juliette
joseph
valentine et juliette je vais je serai
un arbitre impartial
là qui parient sur kant qui utilisent ce
magnifique est maudit les images de ces
deux images de rejoindre s'assurer il
vivait comme ça mais est ce qu'il est as
qu'il aurait écrit ça toute la question
ce serait quand même pas à baisser
j'ai une petite remarque sur les deux
images là de rené descartes à emmanuel
quand c'est des images composites à
partir de plusieurs portraits j'ai
trouvé ça sur internet chercher des
images un peu pour varier d mais émet
emmanuel kant c
vraiment quand où ils sont mélangés avec
le gala non je pensais qu'il est
mélangée avec le gars beau gosse j'ai
pas l'impression
jacoby splatch oui alors ça y est cette
histoire qu'il est souvent tranchantes
très souvent très très souvent presque
aussi souvent que je sais c'est assez
dingue tu tapes quand de google images
puis tombe sur le portrait giacobbi qui
est très beau gosse seulement je pense
c'est un peu parce que les autres ports
tri sont ils sont assez moche et donc
quand tu cherches une illustration qui
veut pas que ce soit trop moche je suis
assez content de tomber sur le portrait
giacobbi parce qu'il vachement plus
jolie
[Musique]
ils ont composé à partir d'autres
portraits de camp puisque quand t'es pas
si moche que ça en fait ça dépend des
portraits
de
ressembler à ça il est assez beau gosse
un peu un peu jaloux
de la saa philosophe de la renaissance
qui est surtout connue parce qu'il a un
nom super marrant je pense à il a fait
des trucs ses côtés elle
salue il a fait c'est de la dignité
d'être humain je sais pas quoi la
liberté tout ça
fait
vivre
non il est pas dans les ordres en fait
mon temps j'ai pas du tour et je connais
très très peu qu'ils dormiront donne en
fait je pique de la mirandole c'est un
mec a essayé d'organiser une grande
séance
grande séance il rassemble
son époque pour discuter des plaintes
est différente et atteindre une sorte de
synthèse entre toutes les thèses de
l'époque et en gros on lui a dit ça
quand même l'air super hérétiques ton
truc
sur la grandeur de l'homme s'était même
si je conçois grandeur de l'homme c'est
le discours qu'il avait prévu de donner
pour ouvrir cette session où des
centaines de philosophes des patries
entre eux et qu'ils ratent jamais eu
lieu
ah oui d'accord ok de 80 ans est
vachement pour moi ça m'a un peu obscur
get
away d'accord c'est bien de faire des
courses et je repars dans mon cours
du coup
je comprends je comprends j'ai fait une
formation en 10 mai à florian
des formations en ligne de kilos de
course a tout enlevé alors est ce que
tout le monde a répondu à prendre le
risque ouais c'est bon alors 1-2-3
révéler vos réponses alors epictète
quand
on a dû un jour je vois pas du tout ce
que tu as répondu
les deux garçons je vois pas ce que vous
vraiment d ouais c'était 2 c'est un peu
l'un d'eux donc aux quêtes épiques net
epictète valentine qui répond quand elle
locale envers comme dans cornes ah oui
c'est ça
comme d'encore le oui serait quand tu
tagués est ce que les gens quand ils
taguent les affiches leur sac à dos et
il met quant à l'envers je sais pas eh
bien oui les petits dont la réponse est
ce que ça marche eh bien oui c'était
epictète bravo et
pour valentine
et chris
gardé ses forces
mais là plus tôt et revenir en valais on
a des cours de comptes qui ont été notés
par ces étudiants ou des notes à lui est
en fait c'est un devoir moral de faire
du fitness tous les jours pour lui le
sport c'est hyper important en fait
non oui c'est en fait les choses du
corps ça fait tout de suite critique du
de l'épicurisme et donc je suis pictet
stoïcisme assez bon et bien dans le chat
les gens sont fait avoir beaucoup de
gens ont pensé que c'était quand du coup
non en fait quand il il avait pas mal de
faim de pratiquer un peu différent
incombe
non je pense que pour lui le corps était
quand même assez important sens il était
super comme ça
il avait pensé toujours avoir plein de
maladies
hypocondriaque et donc il a écrit
là-dessus
il disait aussi qu'il fallait faire des
dîners c'était super important
oui un webinar il avait une obsession de
la façon de sa vie chaque jour il a
déplacé sa part des invités à ca sert
pas tu sais pas c'était samedi matin il
fallait bien dormir tu vas y faire les
boire mais pas trop faim il était un peu
et puis que rhénan tu vois dans sa façon
j'ai l'impression de vivre sauf que
c'était nul mais
épicurien vraiment bons termes enfin oui
baptisa epicure et mon sens propre du
terme c'est à dire que des ces documents
n'étaient pas des gens qui effectivement
effectivement qu'ils aient des excès tu
vois
les bras juste un truc j'aimerais bien
refaire le même straw poll après pouvoir
continuer à comment on peut faire bien
là
donc la deuxième suggestion quand je
fais pour [ __ ] ça mais non excusez-moi
je suis désolé de ce que d'habitude les
plus gros problème c'est que d'habitude
quand je fais un straw poll jeu peut
relancer le straw poll sans recréer un
autre juste en effaçant les résultats
y'a pas un moyen d'effacer les résultats
parce que là du coup ça m'embête de
[ __ ] il ya un moyen légal un point de
plus parce que j'étais peut-être
j'aurais pu faire ça s'arrêtait là c'est
d'être là cela réuni cerner cette
[Rires]
deuxième question fait y'a pas 20
questions liées cry 2 sur 20 mais j'ai
pas eu le temps de faire 20 questions y
en a je dis pas exempt combien nettement
mois en réalité ça fera un petit
suspense serait pas consensus quoi ça se
termine et à la fin il ya un peu des
questions des questions sans qcm à des
questions il faut donner directement la
réponse parce que c'est plus facile
deuxième question qui est pas trop
difficile c'est possible que vous
connaissiez mais je pense pas tout le
monde dans le chat se moquer de la
philosophie c'est vraiment philosopher
alors est ce que c'est
diogène de sinope qui aurait dit ça ou
michel de montaigne michel michaut
blaise pascal
voltaire albert camus keckeis bonne tête
endroit que ça me frappe à chaque fois
que je fais des recherches sur sur lui
ou raphaël ans au val bas âge étaient
sûrs
alors
j'aimerais dire c'est déjà
de voir que franklin mayer a répondu en
taule mais c'était avant que sa fiche
parce que c'est presque des vies table
on peut sentir venir le truc alors oui
alors du coup je vous redonne le straw
poll si vous voulez aller pondre pareil
même système vous répondez 1 2 3 4 5 6
avec ça vous pouvez début la citation
j'ai écris
pas du tout chez moi donc j'ai pas
retenu qu'elle était la liste des noms
alors dieu c'est michel montaigne pascal
voltaire albert camus et on trouve à
la ceinture
du coup du coup du coup du coup
là je vais regarder les résultats du
jour
aucune pression que c'est un piège c'est
un piège là j'ai l'impression que c'est
un piège aussi
mais c'est se moquer ça fait trop
langage 20e siècle
le temps ça pourrait être une traduction
des résultats sont très partagés dans le
straw poll c'est intéressant c'est ce
que tout le monde a une réponse parmi
mes invités de marque
une réponse
alors
3 2 1 donnez vos réponses révélations
alors il est entre bonnes pour juliette
voltaire pour valentine l'a6 raidir
entre vannes pour joseph et je vais pas
lire le tiens encore une fenêtre à
l'écran
elle a écouté aucun d'entre vous n'a la
réponse soit aucun d'entre vous n'a la
réponse la réponse est
non
j'ai dit et cdh en plus c'est à côté
d'une formule qui est assez fade je me
souviens assez bien qui il fait un peu
le même genre de trucs sur la morale il
dit
se moquer de la morale à chaque pas
retrouvé le même truc genre se moquer de
la morale
c'est vrai mais oui tu vois ses pin à
ses esprits tine est éprise de fait a
battu voir
mais voilà oui mais il ya ces jolies
paragraphe dire si je me mettais en
entier connaissent et finalement le
style de pascal très éloquent se moque
de l'éloquence la vraie morale se moque
de la morale voilà c'est à dire que la
morale du jugement se moque de la morale
de d'esprit qui est sans règle car le
jugement est celui à qui appartient le
sanctionnant comme les sciences
appartiennent à l'esprit la finesse et
la part de jugement la géométrie celle
de l'esprit se moquer de la philosophie
c'est vraiment philosophie et la
nourriture du corps est peu à peu
plénitude de nourriture et peu de
substance ce à partir en couille
ces experts un sacré pari fou c'est très
fort et du coup dans le chat vous avez
fait à peu près les mêmes erreurs donc
voilà c'est pareil on était comme ça ça
fait vraiment en tornade c'est une
tornade avant l'heure
c'est d'un côté j'étais enfant je me
disais ça va être un piège parce
qu'entre elles seraient et et ne pas
faire de la philosophie c'est vraiment
philosopher la rue les clubs paradoxal
mais ici c'est lorsqu'on ne cesse de
philosopher que lorsque nous sommes
vraiment
c'était mieux dans la bas déjà se moquer
ça évoque quelqu'un qui rigolent en fait
et papa pascal du coup
bas même si pour moi c'est vrai que
c'est assez chiant tu vas j'écris
beaucoup sur le divertissement et sadi
verte feu
[Rires]
je l'avais comme oeuvre au bac de
littérature
donc je débute ce machin là moins d'état
moins des excuses que les autres d'être
contée du coup mais je croisais en
littérature ah oui
dis donc ah oui
j'allais faire remarques méprisantes sur
les littéraires mais je fais
du coup nous ne signons pas la
philosophie je vous redonne le sont pas
le fait hop des fois que vous vouliez
voter une enseignante à la philosophie
seulement son histoire la quête de la
sagesse étant intrinsèquement subversive
est opposée à la conformité comme à
l'autorité le philosophe ne peut être un
bureaucrate qui a écrit ça
arthur schopenhauer
comment dix prénoms merde on bakounine
mikhaïl louzine mirail rhymes et rahel
frey bakounine donc max stirner
albert camus encore parce que
franchement il est beau gosse je me suis
dit je vais mettre à jour donc c'est à
lui de guy debord l'année juste parce
qu'il est beau gosse
se fait piquer exactement où
idrissa berkane
alors qui donc
valentine a sauté sur son papier je
pense qu'elle a eu de
quoi nous donner trop bien
fait on a deux chiens da qui sait
je tenais à vous ont pas
laissé les cas les genres dits de bord
ne sait pas qui sont ces gens
c'est des anarchistes en gros à temps a
mis trois des anarchistes alors attends
t'es tu pars dès le km je parle de
bakounine et stoner a nom de guy debord
guy debord il a écrit la société du
spectacle
tu sais ce truc que ce truc
je ne sais quand
discours sur la société du spectacle
sorte d'allergie à six parce que tout le
monde a envie de le citer tous genre de
truc que t'as pas envie de lire parce
que tout le monde le site tu sais ça
fait comme damasio quand tu fais des
neurosciences tu dis
des trucs comme ça tu les entends trop
par les bureaux d'un
adieu de sf pour préciser les choses
comment il s'appelle du coup l'autre je
ne sais plus
ce que ça veut dire
au bien-être de neurosciences antonio
damasio avis antonio
d'erreur de thé merci investigations ce
serait moi j'aurais pensé nietzsche
parce qu'il avait un truc contre les
fonctionnaires non non non ce n'est pas
l'histoire de la philosophie
je me dis le terme de bureaucrates et
très
fin 19e début 20e watchmen avoir
l'utilisent pas mal aussi oui mais ça
veut dire quoi sinon la philosophie qui
passe à
brancher à m eagle effectivement mais je
me disais que nos bureaucrates il était
il devait pas se trouver sous la plume
de hegel parce que
chien perdu pas trop regarder ça fait
vraiment
ça ça me semble anachronique muté je me
trompe en fin de saison
j'aurais tendance à un coût tout le
monde à sa une réponse c'est partout il
faut appeler un ami on peut tout à me
tuer ton propre a mis
beaucoup d'énergie écrit non parce que
je veux mettre un anarchiste mais
pourquoi il enseigne la philo je
comprends le font pas ça non mais c'est
peut-être un doux de ces pas lui tu vois
c'est un indice des prix
nos de maîtrise et et oui oui c'est pas
vraiment y aura d'autres gens que lui il
s'identifie pas dans le new south à la
raison comme comme truc la réflexion ça
peut arriver genre
je connais pas ça
soit un concept en rhétorique faudrait
demander à viktor à clément victorovitch
non pas victor clément ochowicz ça
marche aussi
c'est notamment de chat s'est tu peux tu
peux regarder le chat après tout c'est
un peu le tchèque où les états riches le
fils
[Rires]
du coup est ce que tu as une réponse
quand même on est bon ouais j'ai mis un
truc gauthier 3 2 1 c'est parti alors
shopi bon juliette idriss pour valentine
avec des guides vert donc pour
pour joseph et comme d'habitude la main
lorient mais j'ai d'abord je crée je
tribord de vinça centralisation de philo
frustré valentine qui me régale me dit à
mes gars science et bien écoute
valentine qui a raison oh
[Rires]
vous avez une recherche avancée alors
qu'anne twitter
philosophie
42 km par de fil aux
essais
mais en fait j'ai parlé le contexte est
il re tweetent y cite un tweet d'un
gamin qui rentre en terminale et qui dit
ah quand même c'est vraiment nul la
philosophie tels que nous l'apprend à
l'école tout ça
tweet
nous deux est pris à huy en le campement
ils s'identifient pas à ce nouveau genre
c'est nouveau voila voila si on est trop
nul pour enseigner vraiment la
philosophie de ce qu on peut se
renseigner son histoire
les gars
vous avez vous avez tout simplement
parce que vous êtes tous porter le truc
d'avant franchement je regardais un
petit peu le voyant le straw poll qu'est
ce que ça a donné
ça m'intéresse du coup
les résultats
magnifiques ça te voyons qui a répondu
5ème annoncé six la bonne réponse est
très peu juste une personne qui a
répondu 6 mai tuée bravo d'alors on a
tous répondu
voilà
le mind tricks message vous êtes
totalement manipulée c'est cool tu ne
m'as pas tout avec léa il est plutôt
beau gosse 1 sur cette image renvoyée
peut-être pas mais je pense que les gens
le chat peuvent apprécier le truc mais
j'ai en tout va si vite je trouve tous
les mecs beau gosse toi
pas du tout non mais s'il joue tellement
ça ridicule
si moi je
du coup ben voilà
très très faim je vous fais un peu
méchant de james bond sur l'image c'est
mon cas alors monsieur monsieur bond
vous pensiez m'avoir mais grâce à
l'aller des grâces
bien passons à la suite je vais aussi
réinitialiser le straw poll
à celui qui a trouvé à celle qui a
trouvé dans le tchat l'unique personne
qui a eu la bonne intuition
réinitialisation hop
voilà
je vous donne le lien des fois que
troisième truc ah ok voilà j'ai fait
bugger le truc j'ai oublié de ces petits
un peu de philosophie hunting l'esprit
humain à l'athéisme mais
l'approfondissement de la philosophie
porte l'esprit des hommes vers la
religion
j'ai totalement oublié de le faire cela
en fait froid un commentaire facebook
[Rires]
le troll
un peu de philosophie incline l'esprit
humain à l'athéisme mais
l'approfondissement de la philosophie
temps quand je lis ici des hommes vers
la religion et donne des les
possibilités à part et d'autre les
possibilités c'est premièrement francis
bacon
deuxièmement nicolas malebranche
troisièmement david yum
quatrièmement antoine de rivarol
cinquièmement louis pasteur et 6e mans
un commentaire facebook et j'ai oublié
par les illustrations sa meilleure ça
m'aurait fait marrer de m un mec qui
écrit un truc sur facebook ont mal géré
on fait ça à larache aujourd'hui
mais ça m'a pris du temps de faire ce
petit questionnaire de merde
je crois que c'est lié genre que c'est
pas lui qui l'a fondée ni rien ils
datent du xviie siècle c'est
non dentelles du xviiie je sais plus
exactement
mais c'est en référence à lui je ne sais
pas pour quelle raison mais
effectivement cessé c'est triste pour
lui ça dépend à quel point ils partagent
des idées à vos questions mais s'il ya
un côté un peu triste quoi t'imagines
tombe on devine
droite quelques siècles plus tard c'est
la consécration
aucune idée
c'est tellement roundup
tu es allé sur citation points comme
pour faire ton trop powerpoint
[Rires]
je me suis déjà certaines destinations
ça n'arrive
mais je pourrais raconter c'est ce que
tu penses elle si je les trouvais dessus
mais pas directement enfin je vous
expliquerai après parce que ça s'est
compliqué
dit ouais du coup ça me donne un petit
indice
francis bacon un parent de kevin
absolument pas il ya beaucoup de gens
qui s'appellent bacon dans l'histoire de
philosophie et
il faut pas faut pas se tromper bien
j'ai une maintenance et à me faut un
doute est ce que c'est vraiment francis
bacon est pas
moins une autre
façon comme j'ai pas illustrer les
patrons du coup
oui c'est ça il ya le pas
quand on est philosophe quand on
ya roger bacon aussi qui est genre
médiéval s'est dit pas de bêtise c'est
pas une histoire comme ça j'ai fait des
bêtises
moi je pensais à l'auteur du nouveau
morgan um c'est bien francis bacon donc
oui oui
c'est lui qui invente la science à peu
près quoi
servez les choses vraiment de très très
près on va bien se concentrer et puis
comme ça on trouvera ça sera vachement
mieux on fera des délices de choses
tirons légende comme quoi il serait il
serait mort de pneumonie après avoir
gavé des oies des neiges pour voir si ça
les conserver plus longtemps
c'est là les gens qui traînent
mais pourquoi je voulais faire quoi j'ai
pas compris cette légende qui traîne
depuis sa mort
ça a été empêché de se décomposer plus
rapidement je passais un peu le test sur
le frigo quoi
attenton plus bien francis bacon
non pour la science et pour pour les
oies contre les oies
du coup répond moi je répondais vous
avez tous répondu c'est bon vous êtes
prêts
on a un peu perdu florian qui kg mais on
part du principe que de sebha et ses
petits 3 2 1 aller eu parce qu'il a
montré de façon alors bacon pour
juliette malebranche pour valentine
s'est
choisi un homme n'était pas dans la mls
ça va être fou se faire dans la liste
m'a dit que j'avais pas vu une branche
je vois pas trop le concept dc100 mais
c'est une branche avec un oiseau dessus
c'est joli
6 1 commentaires facebook pour
et florian il faut dire que tu ne nous
décrypte la réponse aussi pour pallier
ces déconne on déconne à 35 tonnes et
bien bravo je ne sais pas si je pense
pas avoir fait de dimanche 10h
tant pis eh bien oui c'était
effectivement bacon bravo à vous me
julie lte il approuvait il voulait
prouver l'existence de dieu non mais
comme
j'en sais rien si prouver l'existence de
dieu alors huit ans dans une expliqué
structure venir j'ai envie de le faire
mais en fait cette citation là où plein
de variantes allez on la trouve très
souvent sur internet et du soin en fait
c'est en cherchant et tout sur la
philosophie un peu j'étais tombé sur
cette citation là et je voulais trouver
la source et c'est super compliqué j'ai
fini par trouver en tapant un truc en
anglais et ses draps pour comme c'était
il y avait plusieurs sources notamment
il y avait antoine de rivarol et
beaucoup louis-pasteur aussi c'est
souvent attribuée à lui bastien watan de
rivarol ou à david yow aussi parce que
d'amis parce que youm effectivement le
souci de nous piéger quoi bah ouais
c'était plus
elle est belle et papin elle est souvent
mal attribués effectivement mais quand
la tribu à francis bacon ce qui arrive
assez souvent aussi
l'attribution et c'est la vraie
formulation surtout parce que souvent
c'est des trucs genre un peu de foi
éloigne de dieu beaucoup de fois non je
n'entends
[Rires]
ok
donc voilà donc c'est une situation qui
est mal attribué très souvent mais la
base c'est francis bacon c'est cette
formulation la abbas d'athéisme et de
religion et pas deux et pas de science
et de dieu
voilà
j'aime regarder aux griffes c'est un
animal dans harry potter
[Rires]
vous n'êtes pas trop sûr
ah bah c'est mon métier coûte
juste pour garder qu'est ce que vous
m'avez répondu vous étiez 3 c'était
quand c'était quoi c'était david youm le
situe pas de bêtises ouais c'était david
yum et ouais c'était très partagés vous
n'êtes pas mal planté bonne réponse
était 2 ça non un iceberg c'était le 1
c'est le cas à huy a donc très peu de
jambon et b
comme tu avais commencé à dire que tu
avais d'abord trouver quelque part sur
internet avant de le trouver avant de
trouver l'origine je suis trop malin
c'était sur facebook la page a donné un
demi point parce que très clairement tu
peux très souvent l'avoir vu par
facebook introduit point les
commentaires un peu chelou souhaité
vidéo tu vois genre qui sort de nulle
part c'est ce genre de choses là jordi
d'accord
hop c'est reparti du coup 4e quatrième
extrait
il est pas facile sur ce qui est le plus
manqué à la philosophie c'est la
précision il faut amener la philosophie
à une précision plus haute la mettre à
même de résoudre des problèmes plus
spéciaux faire d'elle l'auxiliaire et si
les besoins là réformatrice de la
science positive plus de grands systèmes
qui embrasse tout le possible et parfois
aussi l'impossible contentons nous du
réel matière et esprit mais demandons à
notre théorie de l'embrasser si
étroitement qu'entre elle et lui nulle
autre interprétation de puisse glisser
il n'y aura plus alors qu'une
philosophie comme il n'y a qu'une
science
alors ça pourrait être emmanuel kant ou
auguste comte
ou husserl
personnes n'ont cessé de nous piéger ce
cieux à berthoud carte au code
igor et grichka bogdanoff
j'ai mis une très belle photo
[Musique]
une magnifique photo de igor et grichka
et enfin toutes leurs photos sont
magnifiques
et du coup je vais relancer donc le
straw poll et repartir si vous voulez
revoter sur le straw poll c'est possible
[Rires]
ça ok je sais ce que effectivement j'ai
me berk ça parce qu'il fallait bien à un
moment donné que je glisse une photo de
jackson quelque part ça fait plaisir aux
fans de jackson je sais pas pourquoi
cette vient d'où ben c'est ta passion
pour faire que ça bassam est venue du
vortex j'ai fait une vidéo sur le rire
et du coup je me suis tapé tout bergson
enfin tout son petit essai sur le rire
qui fait juste dommage mais suffisant
pour moi j'ai une copine si tu veux
qu'ils aient écrit une biographie de
personnes aie aie ça a l'air super
chouette je vais donc être apparemment
c'est une rock star avec son époque
notamment auprès des femmes et dont elle
est tournée la taz unis où il y avait
vraiment décollé de l'os était
bas
tout ça c'est assez fascinant son livre
elle essaie de comprendre un peu
pourquoi tu vois il était aussi
populaire
alors tu as vraiment au collège de
france il allait donner des cours et
pitt avaient toutes les femmes du
quartier qui allez tu vois s'assurer que
ça m'intéresse ouais tu veux est 7e et
le libre et sur un an contre lorient
deming a coupé
du coup est-ce que vous avez tous une
réponse avez vous trouvé une réponse
bien 3,2 à révéler vos réponses
compte pour juliette compte pour
valentine en compte et
auguste-comte aussi pour pour joseph et
bergson
le bertrand risques risk la marine
docker jo rien a dit bergeron a tu sais
tu lis ces sacs sont pendus cela met la
pression
c'était personne et je suis très vif 1 g
serait m'ont dit
tu n'es pas répondu personne c'était ta
question je laissais personne mais
pourquoi me comble son est d'accord mais
j'ai pris ce passage à parce
qu'effectivement c'était parfait pour
faire soit car napout compte enfin ce
genre de type à c'était assez parfait
c'est génial parce que je pense à des
clichés allemand mâle sa philosophie
c'est génial
perception de cette 15e fille qui est
pas du tout
donc c'est le début c'est même là la fin
à la première phase est la première
phrase de la pensée le mouvant
c'est la première fois de la production
[ __ ] j'ai honte
de bras tout est dit en riant
moi je vais préparer pour le ms et déjà
il ya ensuite vraiment personne pendant
longtemps c'était dans mon top tiers
j'ai commencé
aujourd'hui tu vois pourquoi si je la
dois écrire un jour un bouquin
voilà
alors
on l'a perdu c'est pas de ma faute
quelque part
que stephen king
c'est bizarre mais moi ce qui m'énerve
et c'est qu'en prépa quand tout le monde
parlait de personnes c'était un peu avec
des étoiles dans les yeux et c'était un
peu genre on a des hippies tu vois on
adore d'acceptance à m'énerver
[Rires]
carney pourrait devoir
ouais moi c'est juste je pensais moi je
retiens la vie qu'avait donnée aux seuls
à propos de personnes qui me fait
beaucoup marré qui dit il n'y a pas de
nouvel argument chez bergson puisqu'il
n'y a pas d'argument
dit en gros tout ce qui fait certaines
images poétiques du mot c'est très joli
mais absolument pas d'arguments pour
justifier qu'il faut voir les goûts dit
on pourrait voir les choses comme ça il
n'y a pas d'arguments pour justifier
pourquoi il faudrait les voir comme ça
on pourrait les voir on pourrait voir la
vie comme un surgissement de forme
continue oui on pourrait mais pourquoi
mais
du coup la plupart des gens répondu
correctement bravo rassemblés pour
trouver la bonne réponse
citation et oui j'avoue une surprise
pour vous envoyer surface était c'était
idéal surtout que c'est un peu
prétentieux et typiquement compte y
décrivait un peu comme ça oui mais même
ce côté oui unification à la
jav est vrai sur je me serais fait avoir
donc voilà france
réinitialisation hop c'est parti
les philosophes n'ont fait
qu'interpréter le monde de différentes
manières ce qui importe c'est de le
transformer je connais ça
alors
les gens dont le chat est ce que
quelqu'un a la réponse ça
m'intéresserait
marx qui me dit oui tu es beaucoup de
gens qu'il ya pas des sponsors il faut
trouver parce qu'en gros on beaucoup de
gens se sont plaints qui avait pas marx
notamment pour cette phrase là que je
suis bon je le mette dans le dans le
tiède en même temps c'est tellement
connu c'est tellement connaît que c'est
ma femme est très drôle donc voilà
première solution effectivement karl
marx
way or karl marx dans les manuscrits de
1844 quoi
à la karl marx non les thèses sur
feuerbach qu
on
va donc car donc soit car marc dans les
manuscrits de 1844 karl marx dans les
thèses sur feuerbach
carmarks dans misère de la philosophie
karl marx dans le capital ou idrissa
berkane
quand même
mais nantes orange met proudhon
la réponse
du coup voilà alors vous pouvez répondre
karl marx mais ça vous aurez qu un demi
point on va dire
[Musique]
vouvry répondre à ses marques il ya
peut-être un piège intel je vous envoie
un truc ne savais pas je suis
peut-être en fait c'est pas c'est pas
exactement ça qu'il a dit karl marx et
du coup en fait je vais pas y avait un
piège
à le pôle oui je vous le redis je vous
renvoie sur la même race en réalité donc
voila vous l'a copié collé quelque part
vous voulez vous la recharge est
simplement vous recharger la page du
trop peu de chance ça renvoie sur le
donc oui beaucoup jours se sont plaints
que je n'ai pas mis marx dans ma vidéo
que et
effectivement après coup je me suis
alors été sans pas celle ci mais y avait
déjà trois philosophes du 19e siècle en
fait dans ma vidéo sachant que je suis
censé couvrir deux mille cinq cents ans
d'histoire de philosophie
si j'en étais 4 ça faisait quand même
beaucoup plus quatre allemands du 19e
siècle
passé avec les allemands du xixème
siècle sont particulièrement enclin à
dire qu'est ce que qu'est ce que la
philosophie
besoins des grands flops des grands
développements donc voilà du coup je ne
sais pas si je regrette mais en tout cas
voilà je le fais ici est-ce que vous
avez tous une réponse oh oui oh oui et
bien allons-y 3
alors juliette répond misère de la
philosophie
idriss pas trouvé cette solution cd
coeur vous fait quoi de mieux oui c'est
toujours le même papier en fait je
recycle ses décrets magnifique
ces 1/4 que tu as écrit tout âge varie
pas voir joseph
t'écris quoi 4 c'est un éclair
un vote a perdu 21 2 oui honte en
c1 4 c'est 1,4 misère de la philosophie
aussi et lorient c'est j'arrive pas à
lire moi je dis attention ailleurs
barça fire bar élias eh bien eh bien
c'est à nouveau à lampard dont celle de
samir khan sérieusement
c'est bien simple orient
barre il est trop fort il est
extrêmement les choses je suis les est
juste incroyable
en plus ça va mieux matin
franchement moi je n'en savais rien j'ai
cherché la source et en gros c'est un
espèce de petit truc a été publié de
façon posthume si j'ai pas de bêtises
c'est très court c'est vince et non ses
onze petites remarques qu'il a fait
peut-être après avoir lu feuerbach en
fait on ne sait pas trop et notez la
dernière c'est celle ci et luminaires un
screen de lui qu'il ait finalement ça
absolument illisible mais c'est pas là
donc voilà c'est relativement connu chez
les ch et les marxistes et les martiens
ma jun mais sinon c'est quand même
relativement 28 savoir que c'est dans
les thèses sur feuerbach
j'avoue les scores c'est 4 pour florian
2 pour juliette et un pour joseph et
valentine
pas évident
il vous roulez en lisière florian c'est
pas fini
il reste il reste quelques questions
encore nous avait largement de quoi
revenir et à la fin il ya une séquence
un peu flashy comme ça vous pourrez très
facilement gagné 4,5 points je crois
[Rires]
ok du coup continuer j'ai même pas
regardé attendait le straw poll qu'est
ce qui nous fait le straw poll je
reviens
quand même savoir qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que le chat répond
ça m'intéresse voyez on est à jour les
résultats hop beaucoup de gens ont
répondu idriss beau succès
ces délais sinon sinon la première cyber
sens a répondu la thèse les tests de
foule sur fire barre donc bravo à ces
six là vous êtes je me disais bon
marxiste comme tu vois milliard de la
philo il dit que la fio s'est passé bien
oui j'avoue que ça collait assez bien
mais excusez pas de vous piéger parfois
a
baissé régulièrement c'est ça du coup
c'est parti pour la suite les
philosophes ne doivent plus se contenter
simplon celle ci elle et elle est pas
facile ok on se concentre
les philosophes ne doivent plus se
contenter d'accepter les concepts qu'on
leur donne pour seulement les nettoyer
et les faire reluire mais il faut qu'ils
commencent par les fabriquer les créer
les poser est persuadé les hommes d'y
recourir jusqu'à présent somme tout
chacun faisait confiance à ces concepts
commeyne d'hôtes miraculeuse venue de
quelques monde également miraculeux mais
il faut replacer la mise il faut
remplacer la confiance par la méfiance
et c'est des concepts que le philosophe
doit se méfier le plus tant qu'il ne va
pas lui même créée
[Rires]
comme ça que tu auras l'oral de
l'agrégation
c'est une mauvaise note
jeudi c'est débile je parte
friedrich inique qui aurait écrit ça ou
gilles deleuze
je crois que le chat n'est fait le
genevois tahri ou deleuze et guattari un
fit ou deleuze guattari
ou idrissa berkane
alors d'où ces bons il veut mieux
répondre ça parce que du coup on a sa
chance
[Rires]
c'est qui guette arish ça ne pas qui
c'est
ça fait non de voiture un peu en fait
je raconterai après pourquoi je pose
cette question si le c'est un pote et
deleuze on pourrait dire je sais même
pas que sinon c'est un psychanalyste tu
veux tout savoir voilà merci
guattari c'est celui qui montent petit
tonnerre j'ai pas la réf
cissé d'hakkari
c'était bien mais du coup il aurait
écrit sa halle 2
ils s'y sont mis à deux pour l'écrire
c'est
tout le monde a une réponse non je
réfléchis
réfléchit donc ils savent pas quoi
qu'ils disent que ça va simplifier les
choses de créer soi même ses concepts
n'ont
pas un truc ingénierie conceptuel
j'avoue que
qui m'en parler si je vois que c'est
avec bâtisse le bihan parlait un peu ça
de
basse et un ingénieur en concept la cedh
non mais c'est pas pareil de les
tweets et de nos tanks baisse maintenant
vrai ces foules du 2 après je sais pas
du tout qui a écrit craquements
moi j'ai été traumatisé par deux on
avait dit pour comprendre nietzsche il
faut lire le nietzsche de deleuze ce que
j'ai fait et après j'ai plus jamais
voulu dire ni deux
c'est efficace j'aime beaucoup de
théâtre et des conflits en plus avec
quelqu'un qui voulait population je
regarde je garde un bon souvenir
je suis pas dire j'ai lu grand-chose de
deux ans garde un bon souvenir donc
après j'étais très jeune abati
attraction est marrant c'est que
700 livres sur nietzsche deux
passages
sont en fait pas de nietzsche des notes
qu'une beach a pris
c'est intéressant très intéressant dit
je suis sûr j'ai dans ma bibliothèque
du coup il ce que vous avez tous une
réponse parce que je brûle de temps oui
vous en dire c'est parti je alors voyons
juliette qui ne répond deleuze guattari
plus des comme ça ça fait 2-2 de réponse
en dhr valentine qui dit deleuze et
guattari ouais je suis je vois les
jo zette qui répondent deux ou quoi
tahri et
florian qui répond je vois pas
de
leçon on est d'accord que la réponse est
bien de la crise
vous avez tous tort c'était amercian
ses tennis m'expliquer ce que moi voilà
en gros pourquoi je fais ça
après dans le stylet relisez le passage
c'est très nietzschéen comme style c'est
après comme thème ukraine
parce qu'en fait le truc voilà plein de
gens m'ont dit ah mais il fallait citer
critiquer ma vidéo en disant ah il
fallait citer absolument le tous deux
sacrés des concepts etc c'est super
connu ça tu meurs je comptais pas aller
si loin dans le temps je voulais
m'arrêter à russell mais bref donc ça me
saoule et que tout le monde y aille
pourquoi t'as pas mis deleuze et cetera
thème pas deux oui c'est vrai mais pas
que pour ça et surtout du coup si je
vais le mettre dans le jeu le mettre
dans le truck d'aujourd'hui et cherchait
une façon originale de naître mais il ya
un passage où il cite nietzsche et c'est
ce passage-là de nietzsche qu'il cite le
judiciaire ça m'arrange émettent ce
passage là du coup c'est ni tu sais pas
deux mais le truc aux mais en fait c'est
là où je sais pas quel point vous donner
c'est que j'ai cherché ce passage-là de
nietzsche est jeune et sauf à ça non
sauf si tu es dans la classe dans les
boîtes à rythmes et voilà c'est encore
un truc débile non mais
du coup la question est annulée je ne
sais pas et franchement si qu'elles
n'ont
rien alors je suis pas bien sûr que les
frappes je suis pas bien sûr que les
fragments 6 mai était déjà disponible
enfin c'est pas gentil
c'est valentine et de toute façon il ya
forcément soin de soi gatting atterri à
un moment avec son stylo qui a cité sa
et donc il l'a écrit donc ses 2000 et
eric
oui c'est de
là
qu'ils ont co écrit c'est un nom qui est
l'auteur quand demande grâce et l'exode
qui est l'auteur de qian inventé ces
travers de la route et donc mais sauf
que si tu cites un truc et tu retrouves
pas la source originelle tu va inventer
fin vous dire ça n'existe pas
c'est un peu notre machine a dit hé bé
non pas du plagiat c'est objectivement
qu'on t'a vraiment la question c'est est
ce que nietzsche a vraiment écrit ça
j'en retiens passage direct la bonne
réponse scénique mais il ya vraiment un
gros doute pas moi quand je vois que
j'ai cherché plein de passagers chercher
des petits bouts j'ai cherché par mozart
l'extrait j'ai pas trouvé de trace de
cet extrait sauf à chaque fois cité par
deleuze et guattari donc ça m'a mené un
gros doute sur la véracité de cette
extrême et si quelqu'un passe donc c'est
ce qu'on fait
vous connais la maison
c'est un paul et
ses propres
créations de concept chez nietzsche en
tout cas ouais c'est sympathique il
s'était d'un passage vision il parle de
création de valeur elle remplacer sa
part concept qui s'est dit qu'on n'y
verra rien c'est pas grave moi je pense
que c'est pas nietzsche est donc
temps que ça sera quand même 10 qui
citait des physiciens et croyait que
citer nietzsche donc au bout d'un moment
ils ont dû faire la même chose avec
quelqu'un d'autre
donc alors dans les dom en réponse à ces
tests et non ouvrées tahri ou alors
idrissa berkane ou alors on me répond
c'est quoi c'était boitard y
voit ça me faisait marrer ce truc là je
pense que là ce qu'ils
racontent dépend des points qui sont
attribués par exemple ce philosophe
français nos propres points
vous propres et donc chez accor
valentine voilà on a tous un point là
non
finalement le c'est un point qui est
indéterminée c'est un point qui se
réglera plus tard peut-être si quelqu'un
trouve et c'est un point quantique voilà
il n'est pas encore observé n'est pas
encore observé on ne sait pas voilà si
quelqu'un si quelqu'un trouve la réponse
mais du coup c'est ça m'intéresse
quand on dit de lui qu'il est on sait
pas trop si on n'y des tout vrai quoi ce
qui me ce qui m'a vu signe surtout c'est
que ce truc là été dit et je ne sais
combien de fois et que jamais la
citation des remis en cause ni remis en
question et ils en ont rien à [ __ ]
parce qu'on est même parfois la sanction
est attribué à deleuze et guattari alors
que bas dans le texte non il dit
clairement nietzsche a écrit ça c'est
tout entre guillemets et ses
compères enfants sont les types de pas
trop cadre du plagiaire peut-être qu'on
fait pas trop canon plus de la création
de citation
en tout cas quand l'auteur c'est deleuze
et guattari clairement on s'en tape un
petit peu que
à voir visiblement créé une citation en
tout cas je sais pas en tout cas ils ont
même réduit que c'est pas reconnaissable
et depuis ça a été re traduit autrement
oui c'est possible aussi je sais pas
mais il ya un mois dans le truc qui
donnait une référence assez précises
avec une pagination etc mais ces genres
dans un truc que pas que t'es pas chez
moi quoi tu me dis page du 115 des
oeuvres je sais pas tu l édition des
oeuvres complètes de nietzsche
tel volume ça met pas des masses donc
voilà bref c'est pas ton frère noël du
coup merci ça me plaît je n'ai pas
demandé
hockey ne fait jamais ça ne fait pas
vraiment non c'est vrai on en a beaucoup
c'est pas pour rien vous croyez que
c'est plus où les [ __ ]
voilà le genre d'accident qui peut
arriver c'est correct du coup une
continuant à temps il ya le chat
quelqu'un demande pourquoi vous n'avez
pas deux mois j'ai déjà un peu speed
mais on m'a dit de lire un livre de dieu
c'était incompréhensible voilà c'est
tout y'a pas d'autres figures c'est pas
que j'aime pas quand je trouve mon
dieu je pensais bien inspiré
tu as dit quoi et enfin
son truc sur trophée au mahb sait qu'en
général ça m'a tellement inspiré
l'écriture proust
dimanche beaucoup de gens c'est que
quand il écrit sur un autre auteur il
est plutôt pas mal il est plutôt
agréable à lire non enfin après je ne
sais pas je pense que c'est bien la
vidéo compte unique de tenues en fait
que l'action
avait écrit un truc sur youtube j'ai pas
trop pleurer en me disant
eh bien
du coup sixième question attention 8e
questions parlons y'en a pas vrai je
vous rassure parce que j écris 8 sur 20
morts et est une tête c'est mieux que ce
n'est pas vraiment ça a duré trop
longtemps on n'est pas allés méritait
rita rapide d'assaut allez on va plus
vite à l'est la plupart des propositions
et des questions qui ont été écrites
touchant les matières philosophique ne
sont pas fausses mais sont dépourvus de
sens nous ne pouvons donc en aucune
façon répondre à de telles questions
mais seulement établir leur non sens et
ce n'est pas merveille si les problèmes
les plus profonds ne sont à proprement
parler pas des problèmes s voyons est-ce
que je peux afficher s frigo qui a écrit
ça donc invention inventeur de la
logique moderne on pourrait dire de la
logique au sens contemporain
ludwig wittgenstein
plutôt beau gosse aussi un peu torturé
rodolphe carle ap huit renner d'enchères
noam chomsky
stephen hawking ou un zélé et éthicien
mois
et attendent et qui entend pas bien
florian je suis désolé
haier away
al tu as y verse et ça le fait pas un
psychanalyste oui
intéressant j'y connais rien du tout je
n'aurais pas que ce serait un non sens
ça me fait penser à
ces carnac quand il se moquait de
heidegger
le néon néon outre quelques ces choses
là tout le monde sait ce que c'est et
his way est un peu triste qui est pas
gelé vraiment nuit le texte sur le néant
qui donne hantise le texte heideger le
texte de carnac qui critiquent heidegger
alors j'avais tout en cours soit et de
coeur à la fac et donc tout début on
avait montré la moquerie de carnac lanza
c'était ville quand même
ouais dommage
et c'est
passionné et plus pour dire ah là c'est
vraiment superficiel comme critique
c'est très superficielle parce que c'est
profond le nez en ayant this quand même
c'est là bas on a fait tout un semestre
là dessus
on peut y passer du temps comme quoi ça
prouve au moins ça du coup est-ce que
vous avez tous une réponse oui je crois
un essai de sourire en coin de florian
je pense qu'il sait il ya un côté comme
salomon
circonspect mais l'interpréter ton
sourire
c'est
3 à
la 40 sortie du bouquin wittgenstein et
si le tractatus yj pas de bêtises oui
c'est ça ça murs de pierre taillé sur
mesure d'infirmer valentino si c'était
vite nourriture peut le montrer
wittgenstein
up ne fait pas partie des dépenses
possibles
la succession joseph ceop c'est et sans
juste
dire des trucs un peu comme ça en vrai
hop
c'est
ouais je peux comprendre la vibes sommes
effectivement j'aurais pu le proposer
sur était marrant et je vois pas ce que
tu as écrit florian
tamis carnac et bien écoute ce sont les
filles qui ont raison c'était
wittgenstein bravo à elle c'était et
c'était effectivement le tractatus
logico philosophique us et j'aurais cru
que tout le monde que tu voudrais
trouver vos
goûts tractatus alors porter son voile a
été vraiment satisfait c'était trop
facile c'était pas possible
numéro de life for being bang alors mais
que j'ai dans ma bibliothèque je croyais
que c'était
les investigations comment s'appelle
votre livre les investigations les
recherches ça dépend comment j'ai tracé
c'était de notre libre donc bon
donc effectivement oui dis toujours que
l'on peut pas
d'un côté il dit toujours là mais tout
est absurde
mais
l'obsession pour le non sens où
dépourvus de sens et expression là elles
sont vraiment assez crucial dans le
tractatus j'avais l'impression que ça à
sa grille est complètement le truc de
médecin parce qu'à la fin il dit
alors voyons peu qu est ce que vous avez
vu vous avez été c'était bien la réponse
2 c'est ça
effectivement 60% du chat a trouvé
wittgenstein donc c'était relativement
facile pour le chat en tout cas batteux
connaissance on n'a peut être que ça en
fait ben oui voilà
on va peut être y voir plus large et
même pas lu la seule a vu ta vie
c'est ça ben non mais c'est une bonne
façon de jouer et je pensais la bonne
façon de la lecture très intéressante
c'est quoi c'est le tractatus ouais j'ai
décelé un cube pendant le court 1 chaque
set et vous avez du riz la perte des
illustrations de d'antona annoncé moi
j'avais 7 ans le canard la
période carey
mais si un schéma williams a day avec
l'aide d'autres jouets il ya un schéma
dans le tract à sa
taille mais aussi en cédant les
intéressés dans les investigations à
l'explication des illustrations des
petits décembre des trous de
il était tellement moderne finalement
une philosophie est un style avant
d'être un système un ensemble de gestes
et d'attitudes avant d'être une
collection de textes et de concept au
sens propre des règles de vie s
friedrich nietzsche c'est le maillot
william james
henry david
thoreau sait jamais comment dire son nom
à l'oral en français c'est
bon vous comprenez donc toro
albert camus encore lui
choisi beaucoup de google jacques
derrida
j'espère que vous voyez comment ça s'est
interposé que j'ai mis non parce que
elle vaut le coup la photo jamie oui à
toutes les photos de jacques derrida
balle de match où bernard-henri lévy
du coup
chacun a répondu
non
ça va bien marcher ou frigide mettrait
cette caricature
une philosophie et un style avant d'être
un système un ensemble de gestes et
d'attitudes avant d'être une collection
de textes et de concept au sens propre
des règles de filles qui ce qui utilise
cette expression tout hanche et aux
règles de vie s'est pas jeté
des formes de vie
pour rappel six mois si vous regardez si
vous avez l'écran du tweet vous avez
vous avez du coup les propositions sinon
je le répète en mitch william james sort
au calme c'est un poids derrida et
bernard henri lévy comment on dit
sérieusement à l'oral tu vas avoir l'air
d'un débile mais tu veux pas non plus
dire toro tu dis mais c'est clairement
pas de taureaux
sans foutu dit oraux tant pis on en a
rien à [ __ ]
j'espère que ça philosophe que j'aime
bien parce que ça a l'air tellement
encore on savourait à la burqa il envoie
un
message aurait pu mettre américaine j'ai
passé si tu veux un ensemble de gestes
et d'attitudes ça fait un peu
ça fait un peu pragmatisme
est ce que j'ai appris que j'étais pas
encore tout à fait prête à ouvrir
ou à la mecque qui est en train de se la
péter 5 est en train de décrire ce qu'on
appelle la philosophie
bon allez j'écris n'importe quoi
c'est bon tout le monde a une réponse
3 2 1 révélée réponse
donc william james pour juliette luis
amado valentinois qui avec decker aussi
c'est mignon
l'a5 de derrida pour pour joseph et
et william james aussi pour
pour florian et figurez vous figurez
vous que il y à bien une gagnante qui
est valentine
[Rires]
si je dis pas de bêtises je suis pas
entièrement sûr mais en fait non je
crois que j'ai complètement perdu contre
des points est ce que vous savez combien
de temps vous avez chacun ba2 du coup
tacite
domo dans mon complet ce que j'ai fait
je suis entièrement sur florian à 4
points joseph un valentine 3 et juliette
3 non non non
date à gagner celui-là tu as gagné 1 à
berkane avant basse et tout est apte à
gagner un autre sinon je crois que tu as
gagné wittgenstein juste avant aussi ah
oui parce que tu as gagné trois fois cas
d'accord de la valentine et juliette
sont à égalité trois points comme quoi
ça alors donc c'est toujours votre
gouverne et c'était dans un article du
point en 2002 voilà et
voilà c'est tout c'est un
chat mais j'ai juste enlever un petit un
petit bout entre
mais entre en fait la station complète
qui pas beaucoup mieux c'était une
philosophie et un style avant d'être un
système un ensemble de gestes et
d'attitudes avant d'être une collection
de textes et de concepts points
nietzsche disait une ascèse au sens
propre des règles de vie voilà juste
enlevé de nietzsche disait une ascèse
vous fassiez plus c'est exactement ça va
c'est une petite référence à nietzsche d
enlever parce que je voulais mettre ni
sur les propositions je vais te nourrir
le chat je reviens tout de suite
voulu bien ton petit chat
je regardais le 2 les réponses du straw
poll est-ce que vous avez été malin
comment on met à jour les citations ça
servait à rien
[Rires]
laksaci ça ils ont trouvé bhl ils ont
senti le petit style de bhl bravo bravo
et félicitations fixation on réfléchit
trop pourquoi vous avez répondu james
aussi vous avez fait au hasard je sais
que je suis assez content que je m'étais
dit qu'est ce que je ferais mètres qui
manquait et souillac jean ça marchait
pas mal ouais
mais titi
de vie
alors attention la prochaine elle est
allée costaud
accrochez vous bien c'est parti on
pressent donc déjà que le phono
centrisme se confond avec la
détermination historial du sens de
l'être en général comme présence avec
toutes les sous des tri nations qui
dépendent de cette forme générale est
qui et qui organise en elles leurs
systèmes et leur enchaînement historial
prédateurs au regard comme asos présence
qu'une substance sache essence tâche
existence entre parenthèses lucia
présence intemporelle comme poite entre
parenthèses qui vous met du maintenant
ou de l'instant entre parenthèses une
présence à soi du cogito conscience
subjectivité co présence de l'autre et
de soi intersubjectivité comme phénomène
intentionnelle de lego et s'est refermé
la parenthèse le logo centrisme serait
donc solidaire de la détermination de
lettres de l'étang comme présence
dans la mesure où intel logo centrisme
n'est pas tout à fait absent de la
pensée heideggerienne il la retient peut
être encore dans cette époque de l'ontt
au théologie dans cette philosophie de
la présence c'est à dire dans la
philosophie à
l'avenir les français du xxème siècle
pour la perturber
ses dents dans la philosophie il y avait
effectivement une italique sur le las
a joui de l'aneth c'est dommage donc
tout ça c'est la philosophie du martyr
mais les rythmes ici j'en ai marre donc
qui s'appelle
alors les propositions je vous les donne
c'est jacques la première position
levinas
jacques derrida toujours beau gosse
bernard stiegler judith butler ah je
vous crois pas je vais j'ai fait une
petite bêtise attendait ces dix là c'est
quoi
cette année a lancé le générateur de
textes c'est bien sûr alors voilà je
leur ai lancé sur un philosophe hegel
heidegger rien explique ce qu'est la
philosophie et je laisse partir là
dessus
voilà donc soit là qu'en soient les
milanais dida soit stiller soit du 2
août leur soient cédés ce qui est fou
c'est que moi j'aurais jamais pensé que
c'est dieu j'ai l'impression d'avoir lu
des choses comme ça
mais est ce que le sait dit il serait
vraiment mettre des mots grecs ont été
bons nous ça se voit que tu ne connais
pas c'est dit c'est dit est très
impressionnant ah ouais elle a
beaucoup joué florian choix qui essaient
de nous dire des choses message que tu
entends comme une sorte de robot c'est
assez
papa le robot je suis désolé je sais pas
si tu essaies de
essaye de dépasser 100 naissances c'est
ça oui il sait y
était toujours à robot
robot peu fluide sinon j'aurais laissé
éventuellement de partir et revenir je
pourrais des rires récupérer ton flux et
les deux trois trucs rêver de derrida
s'était passé c'est dégueulasse
ça pourrait du derrida ça
j'en ai aucune idée j'ai jamais lu du
derrida genre j'en ai lu très peu mais
asseyez florian est partie du coût du
coup je pense qu'il va revenir je vais
essayer de récupérer
attendait ça va être un peu compliqué ça
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le logo
centrisme c'est quand on est concentré
sur ce
alors fleurir je t'entends je pense que
le cha qui voudront pas encore c'est
beaucoup mieux par contre il faut que je
retrouve
ma question
barbara stiegler
c'était bernard stiegler dans la liste
je sais pas si les gens entendent
florian disent qu ils seront d'antan
florian parce que peut-être ce sera plus
simple comme ça tout ça mettra moi
rajoute à la connexion
puisqu'on est ce qu'on entend oui on
l'entend super peut-être je suis désolé
parce que de toute façon au niveau de
l'image c'est assez a oui ma promesse et
que ça ne garantit pas la route quand je
vous demande de discuter sur le tchat
ce que je peux être sur le terrain
puisque puisse contrer ta réponse
moi je supporte oui mais là c'est quoi
ça moi tu parles
oui sur twitch way pour que tu puisse
rentrer tard et prince dans le tchat au
moment où tout le monde donne la réponse
d'accord
a répondu
donner d'autres réponses à vous la wii
nous faisant croire que c'est alors
valentine nous dit c'est dit je plonge
dedans direct et
derrida pour juliette et la 3
c'est-à-dire derrida pour joseph aussi
honnêtement
c'est un sans faute des philosophes
effectivement c'était derrida si la
nappe à combustion désolé mais c'est
effrayant
voilà derrida
charme la philosophie en italique
essayer de groupe et à caméra parce que
tu as an il ya plus ta caméra donc je
fais aussi du couple la caméra sur un
meilleur son mais vous savez quoi ça
veut dire que j'ai de la mairie ce dont
je souhaite avoir la florian disait que
la philo c'est une affaire de style
voilà oui c'est une belle illustration
ouais je suis né qui toi super c'est
mieux la leçon du coup ouais
d'abrams ans et philosophe
et juste par curiosité brion
il est il est toujours avec nous vous
l'entendez non non je suis
fidèle ami nicolas
[Musique]
alors bien méchant bilbo j'ai été
nombreux à penser que c'était s'est dit
mais non non c'était c'est un réel
derrida bravo
que je trouvais que c'était j'ai trouvé
que c'était trop derrida pour être
derrida
l'impression que ça serait un disciple
de d'héritage
c'est très simple j'ai tapé derrida pdf
j'ai pris premier qui tombaient c'était
de la g apologie j'ai cherché
philosophie j'ai cherché un petit peu
juste je suis tombé sur un paragraphe il
sera mené par c'est à dire dans la
philosophie le dis bon parfait je crois
un peu avant et voilà c'est tout c'est
aussi simple que ça m'a pris vraiment
cinq minutes de trouver cet extrait et
j'ai vraiment pas et à chaque fois que
j'ai feuilleté le truc c'était que des
trucs comme ça c'est vraiment
hallucinant
je sais pas non mais alors par contre
pour moi il n'y a pas que des rédacs
l'écrit comme sa plainte jeudi rigueur
des vinasses
tout dire
j'ai besoin d'un côté
performance pourrait soit le pire
possible avec derrida que je retrouve
pas forcément fait que se passe-t-il
quand arrive t-il
du coup philosopher c'est vivre sa vie
et vivre sa pensée
tout est apparue d'un pouce parlera donc
philosopher c'est penser sa vie et vivre
sa pensée je vers initialiser aussi le
straw poll bon j'ai créé une tomate
jeu rennais 6/10 le straw poll voilà
c'est bon maintenant vous pouvez re
voter dans leur folle si vous voulez
j'ai laissé passer sa vie livre sa
pensée soit michel monteil michel de
montaigne j'ai décidé de dire à chaque
fois le prénom c'est super chaud alain
juppé
alors c'est vraiment comme ça qu'ils
s'appellent oui en fait c'était un
pseudo c'est pas tellement
sa caisse du
20 mai qui met à la nique à la surtout
que tu viens de dire assez chiante
directement d'huile at il pensé à moi
justement comme ça on va passer notre
temps à regarder sera juste à la signer
s'appelle pas du tout alain s'appelle
emile
et mines quartier rochambeau philosophe
c'est de vraiment des trolls
je n'ai aucun sens
bref donc alain frau feu
il a été prof de prépa pendant très
longtemps et il a un style très bien mis
les petites formules et les choses comme
ça henri bergson
l'absence de prépa à wind franchement à
nouveau merck bergson y avait des mecs
prendre
deux ans que ses pensées ses droits sa
panda en france c'est de
rendre les fonctions ville
raphaël enthoven ou un commentaire
youtube
voilà je verrais bien cinq mètres et la
[Rires]
ça fait bien
andré comte sponville je trouve n'ont
donc pas un commentaire et reprise à
abandonner et donc sa contrée
parfois il ya plusieurs des frères
possible sa puce
est ce que si on me passe le commentaire
tout de suite sur youtube ça compte ou à
pas mais tu n'as pas bête voilà je
trouve que c'est un bon exemple de ces
cantons discuter et puis on se demander
si on pouvait traiter pareil sponville
et rennes par exemple convie les
quelques uns depuis sérieux et cela met
quand même le fait qu'on puisse se
demander si c'est ce qu'ont ville où un
van damme commentaires youtube c'est dur
c'est un peu trop 2
oui ça pourrait être un commentaire
comme en appel sortant sur ma chaîne
j'ai des gens qui y met des démons truc
on se dit ça se trouve mais son nom
c'est comte sponville il faut pas dire
sponville puisque par exemple ça
ressemble bien ce qu'on vit en effet ça
fait bizarre si tu dis juste qu'on vide
alors il ya plein de gens aussi comblé
la moitié de mon groupe donc il n'y a
pas de raison celui-ci leur a que la
moitié de son temps que lui en garde la
fin
à me - a des fois on a mélangé deux et
on a fait contre ça fait trop noble tu
vois mais ça fait aussi un peu
je vous ai tout une réponse c'est parti
vous êtes prêt donc rentrer ta réponse
dans le
numéro pour notre andré comte sponville
pour joseph andré conso vite pour
florian comme à bergson pour valentine
gériatre autres avoir pu avec eux mais
c'est vrai depuis tout à l'heure je vous
invite à faire écrire en fait peut faire
avec les doigts
donc c'est un c'est à nouveau un sans
faute des philosophes est une lamentable
erreur de là
de la participante géologue
pour moi cela outsiders m c'était
effectivement andré comte sponville et
c'était aussi en fait ça m'a été
suggérée pas été chercher sa part un
commentaire youtube donc j'aurai accordé
un demi point si l'état répondait
[Musique]
en fait le commentaire youtube cité
andré comte sponville en fait ces trucs
là c'était pour te reprocher quelque
chose ce que j'aime c'est cette approche
web matin me reprocher sur un site et
andré comte sponville en lice
adapté au
oui et voilà et il a dit non je ne sais
pas vraiment la source mais il ya un
milliard de source dans chaque interview
parce qu'ils redoutent toujours la même
chose ce garçon est donc notamment ça
fait partie des trucs qui dit tout le
temps dans plein d'interviews talent est
là mais non c'est pas la même c'est
vivre
ses pensées sa vie et vivre sa pensée
philosopher c'est penser sa vie c'est
vivre sa pensée du coup je nous livre sa
passe est vrai que ça veut dire c'est
beau mais c'est cesser c'est bien c'est
beau et par non
à la question qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça fait signe vers quelque chose ce sens
que je marche dans la rue en criant ma
pensée
bah ouais sa vie toi quand non je sais
pas mais on a l'impression que ça veut
dire quelque chose de profond tu
pourrais utiliser une telle étude sur le
truc un peu bullshit et elle est bien
cette citation
gd citation d'albert kahn je suis trop
triste pas avoir identifié la citation
c'était quelques hésitations par qualité
presque tous mois à trouver contre
dans le chat bravo à vous
hop du coup passons à la suite c'est un
ciel un peu longue c'est la raison qui
replie l'homme sur lui même c'est elle
qui le séparent quand je peux vous ayez
déjà que s'afficher plus d'afficher six
solutions directement voilà c'est la
raison qui replie l'homme sur lui même
c'est elle qui le sépare de tout ce qui
le gêne et l'affligent c'est la
philosophie qui l'isolent ses parts elle
qui le dit en secret à l'aspect d'un
homme souffrant perry si tu veux je suis
en sûreté il n'y a plus que les dangers
de la société entière qui troublent le
sommeil tranquille du philosophe et qui
la rage de sont dit on peut impunément
égorgé son semblable sous sa fenêtre il
n'a casse il n'a qu'à mettre ses mains
sur ses oreilles et s'argumente est un
peu pour empêcher la nature qui se
révoltent enduit de l'identifier avec
celui qu'on assassine ses frères
étaient des obsessions
du coup à une citation un peu longue
est-ce que du coup je vais
pas donner les propositions proposition
machiavel obs brousseau spinoza
saint-just où aucun des précédents parce
que tout ça n'est qu'un piège mais on
sait pas vous vous avez deviné
j'avais j'ai bref jusqu'à ions pas eu de
spider man
j'en ai lu par là bas tout les titres
comme j'ai eu des bouts de l'éthique
c'est très chiant à lire l'étiquette
genre tu lis les appendices et les
appendices notre
son prénom c'est oui en fait oui j'ai
pas mis son prénom à saint-just c'est
vrai là en l'occurrence
alain
que les dangers de la société entière
qui troublent le sommeil tranquille du
philosophe qu'il arrache tout semblait
on peut qu est ce que ça veut dire on
peut et impunément égorgé son semblable
sous sa fenêtre
du coup tu peux le faire ça puis il met
ses mains sur ses oreilles s'argumente
un peu pour empêcher pour empêcher la
nature qui se révoltent en lui de
l'identifier avec son bord qu'on
assassine tu
comprends
ça sent que c'est pas que ça pas été
créé au 20e siècle a en tout cas
si car si on décore jetant le cas en bas
de chez toi c'était une personne normale
tu vas rire et vouloir l'aider mais
c'est un philosophe tu vas réussir à te
à dire que l'a321
merci pour cette explication gex c'est
bien d'avoir un prof de philo mais j'ai
un signal
payer pleure de joie chi s'abonner et
quelques minutes merci à toi je sais pas
si c'est une référence à pascal dans le
moral de pascal
[Musique]
c'est sa seule fois que j'ai vu lu
pleure de joie de ma vie donc c'est une
référence c'est ça si la venue à toi
c'est curieux comme le truc
donc à tuer d'un pascalien j'en ai eu
pascal au début c'était déjà là mais sur
le se moquer de la philosophie c'est
vraiment philosophe et
la philosophie
alors je vous rassure c'est presque fini
il va y avoir après l'aller les
questions flash chez moi j'aime arrive
lancé son retard on voit que j'ai
totalement oublié de compter des deux
footings sérieusement les points mais se
rencontrer au replay pour
beaucoup trop de temps libre
arbitre
est vraiment de réponse c'est parti
3 2 1 c'est parti 3pour donc
roussopoulos
pour valentine de ops pour juliette ah
bah oui si t'as pas lutter mais hrosso
manon
ferrand kovar rousseau second disco
heaven la source
les
broussailles dans la liste c'est très
roots triste mais je me rappelais fait
pas du tout du passage j'ai moi oui je
le côté il y avait un petit côté obs
dans le cette différence au fait de se
faire égorger et cédera jamais à ben
jawad est un petit bijou
et
devinez le truc
oui le genre le style et puis le genre
là on va tous mourir mais je suis cramé
les yeux tout ça me suis dit que c'était
bien lui
explications
merci pour tout analyser comme vous
donne des cours de philo quand vous
voulez
merci pour des formations en ligne toi
aussi
enfin je crois que c'est la dernière et
avant les questions flash
la philosophie selon moi ne doit pas
s'occuper de ce que je suis mais de ce
que nous sommes cela signifie que le
philosophe doit être un homme d'action
et non un contemplatif à berkane
alors est-ce friedrich nietzsche âgées
parlant c'est l'autre paul le straw poll
non je ne sais pas si tu sais le survol
de
hockey du coup sûr pas selon moi pour
nietzsche genre
donc la philosophie selon mais ne doit
pas s'occuper de ce que je suis mais
puisque nous sommes cela signifie que
philosophe d'être un homme d'action et
non un contemplatif friedrich nietzsche
karl marx william james sigmund freud
rich man all fit l'air
s'est dit
[Rires]
plus ça va plus le quiz deviendra
t il est temps que j'arrête
compromettant jeune
afrique est d'accord
j'ai toujours classé les réponses par
ordre chronologique tout à fait voilà
vous n'avez pas remarqué de tout début
je m'en suis tenu à remarquer
donc nietzsche marx william james freund
y faire pousser dit que j'aurai lancé
sur la philosophie selon moi et repart
déjà c'est sexiste parce qu'il ya marqué
le philosophe voilà
dans des trains
déjà c'est nul on est d'accord
alors est-ce coutume on a une réponse
non
c'est important
[Rires]
ça va être tragique si on confond genre
karl marx il est rentré qu'à
[Rires]
remplacer it ont fait remplacer hitler
heidegger
s'arrêter s'arrêtait plus safe mais
justement c'est pas ce nom à lévis qui
pleure maintenant quand même
normal entre ce que nous sommes et
l'homme d'action scénographe ok
c'est bon tout le monde a sa réponse
allez c'est parti
pour joseph des crédits y obliger ça n'a
aucun sens cette phrase c'est à
dire c'est que s'il ya 1
500 m 2 à côté comme ça c'est un fait le
calcul est
donc c'est 1,5 tu vas tu hitler ok c'est
bien
tu veux comme pour fiat ans
oui j'y vais j'ai pas vu ce que tu as
écrit du coup moi
c'était l'ia s'est dit ok et flocons va
aussi 28 l'air des deux a voté hitler
est là et bien non ce n'était pas hitler
c'est s est dit on s'est dit que j'ai
lancée sur
plus de 6 sur le mois et là mais j'avais
aussi sur la philosophie selon moi n'ont
jamais lancée sur nietzsche de points la
philosophie selon moi si je voulais lui
donner une petite soeur ne tienne il ya
une citation et il l'a signé freund
du coup voilà peut-être que nietzsche et
freud sont plus ou moins acceptable vous
avez pas répondu vous êtes vous êtes
parti sur hitler ou simplement mieux
du coup c'est presque fini il reste je
crois quelques genres deux ou trois
questions de genre elle était
suffisamment simple pour que vous
vous puissiez répondre directement je
pense donc là ces épreuves de rapidité
vous devez donner la réponse le plus
vite possible
la brave répondre avant
attention 3 2 face à la philosophie est
morte
abbas et okigo ok ok pardon qui ne peut
pas le dire à cox et valentine qu'il a
eu en premier bravo hein j'ai conques c
languedoc aux
kings effectivement c'est hawking dans
c'est la première phrase de son livre
the grand design
bravo et c'est le cas acheté 7 ans oui
effectivement ce serait bien mais moi
j'ai fait une vidéo là dessus et jimmy
aussi j'en ai parlé un petit peu dans
mon bouquin le site
deuxième extrait je crois qu'il est un
peu il est carrément chose le deuxième
extrait oui ça me faisait marrer
celle-ci en fait je me rends compte que
c'est ultra pointue comment tu arrives à
connaître en fait une vitrine est
rarement s'il voulait pas faire une
série de mai en euros explique j'ai pris
j'ai fini de réparer le qcm au dernier
moment mais vraiment le dernier moment
c'était
donc la philosophie européenne n'est
qu'une suite de notes de bas de pages
aux dialogues de platon alors j'ai déjà
entendu ce à quoi je connais
eva bravo excellent excellent c'est vrai
ça aide effectivement qui est de pour
ceux qui voient pas qui c'est c'est le
co auteur avec russell des primes qui va
me mathematica et voit ses acteurs qui
est assez pointue du début du 20e siècle
et donc voilà écrit ça c'est
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord mais je
troisième fois que sa dernière attention
c'est parti je n'ai qu'une philosophie
avec la forme le sourire
je aller jusqu'au bout le poing levé
vers l'avenir lever la tête levée le
torse sans cesse redoubler d'efforts la
vie ne me laisse pas le choix je suis là
ce qui bat le roy s'est dit
bien entendu
tout le chat avec l'arbre c'est moi
qui allais répondu amel bent est tombé
juste le chat
est ce acceptable en fait c'était
la fête je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
reconnu que c'était un même but et j'ai
dit laurie
éliminatoires ces éliminatoires c'est un
bon ben voilà pour ce secteur qui
expliquent elles je pense oui c'est
florent qui gagne j c mais je pense que
je pense c'est serré entre sommation
je veux être bernie ou avant dernier
prend en dernier à un moment j'avais
qu'un point d'écart avec valentine mais
non non et les choses de près doit vous
avez fait des séries de générer fla non
je suis content à faire résume elle en
avait trois j'en avais 4g fait une
soustraction
ah oui pas mal
on sent que tu as été une formation
scientifique
comment en tout cas merci de vous être
traités à ce jeu je suis c'était voilà
c'était moins bien organisés ce que
j'aurais aimé faire mais voilà je vous
ai quand même bien piégé je suis assez
fier sur le début je suis à faire placer
du bhl
de william james ça c'est quand même pas
mal à confondre
conforme à celle william james alors que
c'est surtout sur berge à shooter
est juste est ce qu est ce que vous
connaissez genre jankelevitch j'ai pas
comme on dit oui failli mettre cas de
jankélévitch qui m'avait suggéré ce que
en fait j'ai l'impression que les
enthoven had c'est lui le premier
véritable auteur c'est ça c'est un peu
je sais que canto veulent adore
je sais que quand aux jeunes adorent
jankélévitch les inviter chez pas
combien de fois aux nouveaux chemins
et on sent un petit peu l'influencé
effectivement je pense que c'est quand
même vachement mieux est d'avoir des
trucs
niveau mais c'est juste que en fait j'ai
regardé un chant alain
je vois le genre
sa propre offre de fil pour prof de
philo mais pas pour chercheurs de près
par en être
il
faut penser tout ce qu'il ya de pensa
bhl dans l'impensable oh
non c'est bien jankélévitch il s'appelle
le jeu je ne sais quoi et le nom c'est
quoi il est presque acquis c'est que je
ne sais quoi elle est presque rien comme
ça oui mais presque rien
ne me choque et dans l'arbre
elle est un archipel que je sois
tranquille
[Musique]
je pense que je viens tu as passé
souffert dans ce qu'on a dans sa
scolarité
bon je suis du coup j'ai laissé les
écrans sur cette jeune magnifiques
images de berkane qui n'a pas du tout
dit ça mais qui aurait pu le dire la lie
des philosophes n'ont fait
qu'interpréter le monde de différentes
manières ce qui importe c'est de le
transformer je suis toujours
impressionné quand même que tu as réussi
à trouver que c'était les thèses de deux
feuilles barre ça c'est très fort
on peut voir le chat je n'ai pas montré
les résultats du chat
sur la dernière c'est quoi la dernière à
lui sur ses dix
voyons n'est pas du tout
vous étiez vous avez trouvé ces livres
c'est la réponse is de bravo le chat
vous étiez plutôt bon mais des types
très bon
écouter merci beaucoup d'être resté ça
me fait plaisir
[Musique]
un
ordre ils deviennent des personnes
comment je sais pas combien il ya des
gens en fait je vois pas le nombre je
crois soit ces douze sauts ses 128 ses
128 vous étiez 128 dans le chat va
écouter ça me fait plaisir 112 sebaou
sigean peu en retard le truc 11 après
obs mois deux à bientôt pour un niveau
technique et moi j'aurai un jouet ou
même 100 personnes je voulais trop
gagner
donc voilà on va revenir en europe voilà
que j'enlève mon truc super
le nerf de la belgique etc des astuces
qui a gagné là
c'est la suisse qui gagne avec will et
florian et représentations à lorient est
vraiment en suisse n'entend suis suisse
j'étais installé en suisse et tout s'est
plutôt attaché en france
gt france en entrevue hier
et voit la terre des
transferts et suisse samoa d'argent
mois l'international
[Rires]
désolé
pas tu veux travailler pour jamie ça ça
pourrait être pire tu pourrais être un
post doc c'est
vrai tu es plus des chroniques pour
jamie j'encourage les gens à aller
chercher les sites électroniques de de
valeur tout ce qu'elle a fait pour jamie
pour l'émission ça s'appelle
la fois c'est de faire d'autres trucs
était très drôle je sais pas si j'en
étais pas ce que j'ai vu des deux
essais s'est tapé poisson puis c'est pas
du tout bien mis en avant ce truc là
c'est comme ça c'est comme sur ta chaîne
où c'est comment dire ambiance puis
celle plus
voilà quoi c'est même ambiance et achêne
non non c'est plus plus sérieux comme tu
veux
mais j'étais pas sérieux ok
et l'habillage sonore de ses chroniques
ainsi que
ils étaient trop payés je sais pas
il faudrait vraiment qu'il en fasse
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moi c'était
une horreur mais c'est sympa sinon
en tout cas voilà
la voie de la paix non qui dit tout les
bana hpc de récupérer ton flux
éventuellement en fin de saison je pense
que je vais bientôt je vais essayer de
faire un raid je suis jeune et je sais
qu'on peut faire des raids
qui va gérer des ébats saint-yvi la
dijonnaise chiché ou même à mouthe maya
moto c'est un cane donc c'est le sens
inverse est bon même si je suis plus
normand maintenant c'est fini oh oui
c'est vrai mais si je sais pas de
je suis plus au sud je suis outré de
quasiment du sud
voyons si tu veux yake manqué moreau
vici en ligne justement tant parler
est ce qu'on peut
je découvre ça peut sauver des plus
grands que soient ces bonnes questions
et c'est vrai scoop ce n'est pas moi je
l'aurais imaginé pascal qui écrit sur
tout
aller aux abonnés
cc by night ce serait très bon
qui mais pourquoi pas clémente et
comment il s'appelle clément klimowicz
ochowicz qu elle aille se battent
klimowicz movie sur
les changes
c'est bien beau de parler d'hypothèses
poser deux hypostase mais
[Musique]
ma connaissance des figures de style est
très limitée
des gens sympas
je vais jouer allez on va régler move it
on me dirait bonjour de ma part je sais
pas du tout si calcul qui je suis
probablement pas
donc voilà en plus il n'a pas compris
comme ulysse par mois je crois qu'il
commence switch justement si j'ai bien
compris
donc qu'il est dans le même état de
voir ça
non vous allez rester avec moi dans la
boum
j'ai désolé c'est juste laisser les
scellés viewer qui vont s'ils le veulent
hop si le valley pourront aller voir
clément klimowicz parler de dix petits
pots zi post has et d'onomatopées et de
nos masques
tous ces mots existent
donc
je peux lancer une coupure publicitaire
de huit minutes tiens c'est nouveau ça
fout les options
le raid est prêt j'aurai les prêts lancé
le raid du coup voilà dans dix secondes
à peu près où des brouettes ce sera
raide et est donc merci à tous à tous
d'être resté là pour ce pour ce quiz
quitter mais une folie absolue c'était
vraiment la rigolade mais quelle
dinguerie
vous m'avez régalé
je m'arrêter là avant et super fin voilà
et bonsoir
à bientôt j'espère que vous reviendrez
souvent c'est mieux
ce que j'ai vu je ne sais plus ce que je
dis quelle soirée texan dr mons a
[Rires]
acheté ces formations en ligne